how are your kids doing
they're good they're good they're good
they're yeah they're giants they're i
don't understand in the backyard
it's pickleball it's pretty serious yeah
we're big into pickleball now so i just
got that because somebody told me here
on set i think it was wise told me about
pickleball and i'd never heard of it
well do you play it's yes okay anywhere
else there's a stupid sunday day we wear
all whites just to be extra stupid and
to look like ghosts
i like it because i grew up playing
tennis and i love it but now i'm like
i'm going to shatter all of it yes i
can't play tennis anymore when we first
played melissa got really competitive
and was just rifling bubbles with our
kids and i was like yes let's go easy
she's like no teach them teach
them then also if i see a ball i'm
literally in my head i'm like be nice be
nice be nice be nice be nice you son of
a [ __ ]
and i something something takes over
from years of playing tennis and like i
have hit my kids and i'm like i'm a
monster but and i'm fine until right
when i'm about to swing then it's like
i'm going to murder it
and i can't control it i don't know that
you played tennis so i did not and i got
this house just because of the location
really and there
happens to be a tennis court in my
backyard i don't play it all skate on
and we
do a lot of other things on and ride
bikes but like we don't play tennis i'm
not i don't yeah but now i want to play
tennis with you because i want you to
get really competitive
it's not pretty it's really really nice
and then i want you to watch just two
crazy no no no no no okay fine
[Music]
you